we all had our eyes on Aubry Plaza in
the background during the cast went on
stage but it was this annoyed reaction
that lit up Twitter Union forever
co-star John gries explained saying
since she was blocked he urged her to
come forward but he also wanted to avoid
a wardrobe malfunction with the cutouts
in her gown saying you might want to fix
that first
John says aubry's face was just a
reflection of her dry wit he texted her
the next day you weren't really upset
she responded no not at all when do I
ever make things awkward
season three of the White Lotus is in
the works but what about Jennifer
Coolidge there's a campaign for Pam
Anderson to play Tanya's sister in
season three what do you make of that oh
wow
I just recently saw Pam's documentary oh
my God
we realized they have our home videos
it's amazing you finally get the real
story and um now she's not gonna have
this huge comeback what if Jennifer
played Jennifer's sister no a twin
sister is there a possibility yeah we
can see you back as a different
character Tanya's sister yeah uh I don't
think Mike's gonna allow that more TV
news you producers tried to get Jenna
Ortega to return for season four what
happened there
oh I was devastated I was so devastated
when they reached out because I was in
Romania shooting Wednesday and I
couldn't I couldn't travel back and
forth with the pandemic and everything
like that I tried I tried we share a
certain history we execute them we are
excited for Scream Six what do you hope
fans take away from this movie Ghostface
is a lot more of a scary figure we do a
good job of balancing comedy and stuff
like this but I think audiences should
be prepared for it to be a bit more of a
roller coaster more than anything well
Abbott Elementary fans weren't prepared
for this
Janine and Gregory finally kissing on
the show that was pretty shocked I'm not
gonna lie
then when you see it it was right on
time and the way it came together it
just worked so well and it was perfect
and here's a romance update on Austin
Butler and Kaia Gerber an eyewitness saw
the couple at a pre-sag award party
where they were all over each other
kissing having a blast and looked very
in love but don't expect Kaya to be his
plus one to Hollywood's next big award
show may I ask who you bring into the
Oscars one of my best friends since I
was 17.
there's a guy named James who he uh he
then became my agent and so I wouldn't
have my life as an actor without him and
so it's my profound privilege to get to
bring him with me
foreign